[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space it seems that we don't have
technical issues tonight so we'll be
able to have a live show as far as I can
see for now let's just hope that my
neighbor doesn't turn on her cable TV
and we will still have the Internet so
today is a debate between between bill
gayde who came on the show last time and
bill gate of course is known for the
road I fought Isis in physics in
hypothesis that looks at electromagnetic
interaction and many other questions
including gravity to a rope I pathes
this last time I did my best as a
biologist to try to counter its points
but of course I'm not an expert bill how
are you doing tonight joining us to
offer a more expert view on all this and
to a very true counter to bill gayde we
have peter who is a natural is to works
in experimental and phenomenological
physics particularly as it relates to
testing theories of quantum and
classical electrodynamics are you doing
Peter all right so maybe we can
introduce with Peter since you come as
the Challenger do you take issue with
the Rope hypothesis of Bill and what is
your take generally on it no I am
enthusiastic of some of the ideas that
he's presented they are quite a few that
there are some aspects that are seem to
be valuable in that space seems to be an
attempt to physicalize interactions as
always that seems to me a a nice step
forward it's not particularly unique in
the in that sense but any sort of a
group that's wise any sort of project
that tries to get down to the morgue
Gritty of what's going on is so yeah if
you can take us through that then the
kind of opposition that you will be
posing all right so what are these
contentions wants to make sure I
understand you have a coil sir you've
done something like this before you have
two antennas where do you put a whole
kid on one of them and you rotate saying
the other one now if you have a light
bulb next to one of them it will light
up or not light up you have I mean I had
a little bit difficulty trying to figure
out why in your system if I rotate my
antenna would the light bulb light up
versus not light up all right so we'll
get to bear to hear his response to this
but while he does that Peter if you can
find a way to reorganize your mic it's
in is it possible that we're actually
hearing your mic from your laptop
instead of the one you have close to
your mouth because I'm feeling that
there's lots of noise coming
right so maybe we can have we will move
to build while Peter figure this out
bill on this point that he addresses
your theory with and perhaps generally
for our audience if you couldn't reduce
your theory and the point of the Rope
hypothesis yeah and I think we have to
start at a lower level here primarily
because of the audience we have out
there you know we're talking about
people who are not familiar with
sophisticated experiments or you know
things that are beyond their reach
most people are tangential II related to
you know to physics and where I would
start at least the way I look at things
is that in order for the audience to
follow you know my reply to such issues
as raised by Peter is that we have to
establish some foundations and this
takes us to where we were last week in
our discussion with the UK FG and I'm
referring to specifically to the what I
call the golden principle of physics and
that states that by the way that's my
golden principle I'm saying now it's the
foundation the number one principle
physics a cynic wonnum non-negotiable
principle and I'm saying
physics requires an object you can't do
physics without an object and and so the
first question that I would have as an
answer is do you agree with this Peter
do you agree that physics does require
an object because we were not able to
resolve that the other day with jfg I
think the question that he's trying to
ask is and all of nature be described by
natural phenomena but specifically
physical phenomena with objects the good
I guess the question is as follows you
know can there be any phenomenon
occurring in the universe objects no
matter nothing whatsoever well
so that I would might ask can objects
move so must fill your it boils down to
yes I get your point
but yes I would say probably erupts
probably okay I guess that's cool to
know for the best and I say this because
so far as we know in the way we perform
the mathematics in a literal way that
that is what we do and that's we
minimally assume that to be the case
yeah except that that's not what the
results are in other words the problem I
see with physics today is exactly there
at the foundations for example you
present here a a case specific case you
know it could be any case you could talk
about for example the slit experiment
polarization many experiments that a lot
of people out there are only
tangentially familiar with some are not
even familiar with them at all and I'm
saying the the big problem that I find
right now and there's a big problem in
communication between the mathematical
community and the lay public and you'll
see a lot of question because of this in
Quora
for example where people ask questions
and that's because the answers are you
they're receiving from the mathematical
community in no way if they can not
relate to those answers why because
they're in the motion of concepts they
say look we transferred energy we moved
the mass we work time and people say you
know these are concepts what do you mean
you moved a mass what do you mean you
you of course
you know particle carries a force what
kind of language is that we're talking
about concepts and people are in the
mathematical community are in the
business of moving concepts and the
question is can we do that or can we
only move objects and if we can only
move objects you know what is an object
and we require objects and physics now
so
to that I am going to say I already so
your left statement there I thought we
would save that priority partially
answered this and that one can make an
interpretation of the mathematics such
that with you removing physical objects
it is not inconsistent with current
mathematics now your point on
communication I mostly agree I think
there's a problem where there's lots of
strange phenomena that we're not so
certain of and generally speaking the at
least people in physics are quite
conservative in respect to not pinning
themselves down to being wrong and
putting mud on their face I agree there
quite a bit you know but that that means
that they don't have the courage to put
their you know their careers or their
honor on the line you know if if people
make a mistake well you made a mistake
but to keep that away and you know keep
it up yeah that's a very honorable I
might I go completely out on the field
and I'm saying look we need an object to
do physics and if someone has a problem
with that you know I'd like to hear the
other side of that story then I go to
the next step and say you know what is
it if we need an object we have to
define what the word object is because
otherwise all we're saying is look we
need an X to do physics but we're not
going to define X no obviously you need
to define what X is and so that's the
next step so I would say you do need an
X and if an object's you also don't need
as you say in some of your papers that
you write that's you need both you need
qualitative descriptions but you also
need quantitative descriptions as well
we can't neglect achill I would also say
to that and certainly certain tests
certain theories or hypotheses they're
not really theories they're hypotheses
of course they need to be tested and the
other thing in terms of how conservative
some people come up with they do not
necessarily propose experiments for
to say in a reasonable amount of time
demonstrate that's their pet theory is
correct so this is another issue with
some of the glorious things people come
up with
however elegant they might be this is
another I would say shortcoming of of
people developing theories I don't agree
that we need to test theories I don't I
don't think we need a experimentation I
say has nothing to do with science it's
just like I'm saying I know people say
I'm crazy what is science science is
rational explanations I need to explain
that's all I need to do and I explained
so that someone understands the
mechanism that I'm proposing in the case
of physics right yeah I don't test
I don't verify I don't prove because
that's an individual manner if you want
to prove something in your basement and
say look I'm gonna run a lab and
experiment and I'm gonna try to test
your theory all you're doing is trying
to convince yourself whether the theory
is correct or not - for you have
believed but but but it doesn't a
mechanism is something you don't prove
and a mechanism something you explain
objectively so that someone understands
know they have to disagree because first
of all I'm not sure why you either need
to point to being an individual endeavor
testing things you know we are social
creatures we should try to work together
to try to you know get things done and
actually resolve problems I would say we
are designed that way to some degree
however you'd like to call design the
evolution their evolution or whatnot now
the other thing I would say about the
other day is that I can come up with
multiple interpretations
yupi the mind is very inventive you
coming up with lots of interpretations
to describe what's going on
in fact there are multiple
interpretations describing similar
phenomena and you can they can all be
consistent with the current all the
current natural phenomena that we see so
it comes if you want your interpretation
to be valued then you should put it to
the tests in order to show that it's the
right interpretation if you don't think
it's the right interpretation or you
don't care that's fine then I guess you
can be an individualist and go ahead and
stain your your basements and then go
ahead and and not demonstrate that what
you are saying is accurate yeah and
again because belief is a personal
matter that's why it's individual
because one thing is for the prosecutor
to explain to the jury what happened or
how his theory whatever it is he's
explaining another one is for the juror
to believe what he just said now as you
say there could be different theories
you have the defense that usually has a
different theory than the prosecutor
right that's why they're fighting in
there and they have two different
theories each one tries to convince the
jury and you know through some kind of
experiment it could be you know in the
in the in the court of science to say it
that way
what are we trying to do we're trying to
convince people to believe like we do
and so you have someone who says well
space-time is work that's gravity the
other guy says well no it's a rabbit
time's going back and forth delivering
negative momentum again so on you have
all these different theories and all we
need to do the the impartial viewer out
there that will calm the juror all he's
got to do is listen and understand okay
what is your what is your theory my
theory is this when a okay what is your
theory
my theory is B okay he just understands
that he collects that he reaches his own
conclusion and that's his personal
belief his personal religion but we are
not in the business Janna is a personal
religious a personal book do you believe
in God well this guy says yeah I believe
in God the other guy
says well I don't believe in God so
who's right no yes I have proof for the
existence of God the other guy says I
have proof for the non-existent
everybody has proved but proof means
that he has been convinced of his belief
and he's trying to come in someone else
of his belief that's different than
science science only explains
objectively so that you understand now
so let you believe so that was quite I I
understand where you're coming from I
think there is a little bit of a
disconnect I don't quite know where it's
coming from I seems like since you're
talking about objects you at least are
at the moment convinced that there are
this is a little bit more metaphysical
than I want to get and I hope that we do
move on from this it seems that you are
laying a your you are looking for an
objective interpretation of reality yeah
but you do not want to you are not so
confident us to say that that other
people ought to also be convinced that
there's an objective reality exactly I
don't I'm not here to convince anyone
listen listen I'm not your Daniel I'm
not here to persuade anyone I'm not here
to recruit anyone I'm here to explain a
theory and a mechanism so that someone
understands it only understands it
whether you even in it or not whether
you believe that's the way mother nature
runs your shop that's your personal
business that's something in private
that you do at home but yeah at the
conference at the conference all I do is
explain so that you understand now I you
know it's human nature to try to provide
evidence in support of the theory that
one has and that you know I do it as
well I I'm a criminal as well for that
kind of thing I try to provide evidence
I'm saying look here and look there but
but the point is that you know a theory
is only an explanation and objective
explanation for the purposes
of understanding as long as we keep that
in science and only and limit that
within science then we're okay it's only
when we try to convince people through
evidence and throws alleged
interpretations you know that we get
into trouble and that's when we cross
the line into religion so to this I
would say that if you have some sort of
model that predicts things I know you
don't like the word predicts but if it
does predicts things it claims to melis
points to something that takes another
step forward that other models don't
have I mean yes you can go ahead and
just talk about the present and be
present in the look to the president in
the past but I would say that at least
it's sad that one would not want to look
to the future
and try to say oh yes I'm going to say
and pick up extra next extra step and
say well my theory is not only describes
everything that we know but it also
describes things that we don't know yeah
let me let me give you a prediction of
something we don't know that we do know
but we don't know and I predict that
tomorrow at two o'clock there's gonna be
an eclipse of the Sun okay for example
okay where did I get this well I got
this from you know from past
observations etc and I can do this
prediction I can do the calculation and
say look tomorrow two o'clock there's
gonna be an eclipse of the Sun that's a
prediction that's got nothing to do with
science science is telling me why
doesn't the you know why does the moon
fly out of the solar system what causes
the moon to stick to us why doesn't you
know what prevents it from flying out
that would be appearing I can give you
another prediction I let go the pen and
it falls to the floor and I can predict
that consistently believe me I'll let go
the pen it always falls to the floor and
I can say look I predict that the next
time I'm gonna go to the pen it's gonna
fall to the floor that's a prediction
that's got nothing to do a science
scientists tell me why the cause what
causes the Pend of
all to the floor not to the ceiling
that's that science that's objective if
I can explain that the mechanism right
mother nature uses to produce that
effect then I'm a scientist I will just
present my own opposition to bid and
then you can do yours bill when you
explain when you understand some
mechanism or some hypothesis these thing
will invoke entities they will invoke
gravity being something or being
something else this will lead to
differences can you at least acknowledge
that there are differences in what is
expected when I when I invoke an
explanation versus another
for example the theory of relativity
involved there is a difference in the
mechanism involved in its explanation of
gravity with respect to quantum physics
for instance so that difference is often
what ends up being the prediction it's
often because we we pretty we say that
there is a difference between the two
theories we expect to find different
things in the universe when we look for
these things yeah but all you said is we
have Newton said well that's assuming
God does it with particles okay so the
son strolls some kind of particle at the
earth and it produces his mass times
mass divided by distance squared that's
his theory and you have Einstein coming
in there said look gravity is the
geometry of space-time
what spacetime produces gravity so you
have these two explanations right now
you don't have to believe either one you
can accept one you can accept the other
or you can accept none
these are explanations these are
physical interpretations for equations
and they said look money question tells
me this or leads me to believe this the
other guy says I have this other
but all you all you need to do as a
scientist is be objective and say okay I
heard you I heard you and I'm gonna take
them into consideration what decision
you reach whether you like this theory
instead of the other that's your
personal business that's a belief that's
got nothing to do with science I mean it
does have something to do it with
science to the extent that we can state
today that Newtonian mechanics is less
precise than relativistic mechanics for
a certain domain of physical observation
right and that's science there isn't
that being true or not less precise has
nothing to do with science what does it
matter if one is more precise than the
other mathematically what does that tell
us about the mechanism does that search
engines explanation for his more precise
theory does his explanation make any
sense the fact that he's saying that
gravity is work space the fact that the
mathematics is mathematics is closer to
the correct value than Newton's and can
predict the value of the Mercury's you
know very Hylian or whatever more
precisely what does that tell us about
the mechanism the mechanism is that
ancient proposes is that there's a
concept unimaginable concept called
four-dimensional space-time in its warp
and that causes gravity
that's nonsense so whatever his
precision you know whatever advantages
precision gives him has nothing to do
with is irrational explanation all right
that that is true that relativity is not
a Nexplanon terry theory however I know
that when we find an explanation it's
gonna have to fit with relativity it's
not gonna have to fit with Newtonian
mechanics if that were true jfg if that
were true NASA would not run their ships
with a Newtonian mathematics they do not
use at all well hold on for a second
for the most part Newtonian mechanics is
good enough and it's nibbler
it's similar in certain domains it's
more simply describes nature there's
simpler mathematical objects to deal
with that's why NASA uses Newtonian
mechanics now there are physical
phenomena qualitatively that you cannot
explain with classical Newtonian optics
or for that matter it would be it is it
I don't even see how you can I mean I
don't think it's very easy to even
explain with Wigan optics wave particle
wave wave office yeah
so you the Eclipse you brought the
Eclipse and you brought up gravity falls
bring this experiment up of course the
point was that when you look at the
night sky you look at the Stars the big
generativity
thing that phenomena we cannot we could
not explain for example is why when the
Sun comes the moon comes in front of the
Sun and then we can sort of see that if
we can better be able to see the stars
behind the Sun why do the Sun the star
suddenly seemed to move closer to the
Sun another phenomena according to
Associated special relativity is I have
these cloths that click up and down that
are very precise and we know exactly
what's going on and as they orbit around
the Earth there the the signal that they
send to us depends on how fast they're
rotating around the earth so those two
phenomena cannot be explained I would
say with classical flaking or particle
off particle physics without special
relativity in general relativity despot
yeah but how does a special in general
relativity explain them what is the
physical mechanism why does why what
causes the climb though slower that's
what we want to know sure
and so then the question becomes with
phenomena then you need to construct if
you want it to be objective system you
need to construct and then jump to the
interpretation around the principles
that you have kept see
now I split something out by the way I
should put something at the Einstein for
example when when we did not know that
that's the thought the Stars when the
the Sun comes when you have Eclipse we
did not know that the stars were going
to come closer to the earth so this was
there this is something that he
predicted and the age added veracity to
his experiment that starts to cast doubt
on the other experiments that's the real
power of predicting future events that
we don't know might hurt yeah but the
fact that you put an equation has not
given us an explanation I'm saying
physics science in general has to do
with explanations with physical
interpretations the math is irrelevant
totally how mother nature runs her
universe I need to know what gravity is
what physical object is mediating
gravity I need to understand what
physical object is mediating magnetism
you know I need to be have the the eyes
of God to see that invisible mediator in
order to have an explanation that's what
we don't have today we have a lot of
math and no explanation so to that I
would say I would go back first to
perhaps the conservative nature of some
physicists maybe perhaps older ones and
it is in the language in which they use
they describe these phenomena they talk
about for example the fabric of
space-time that bends space so this you
can take to be a physical object it's
not that's the point whatsoever to
physics
that's one wide why do you say that
because it's a concept is how a concept
or an object
he's a fabric an object or a concept
well we're talking about the fabric of
what what is this fabric fabric of space
and time is a concept
so we're making a fabric out of concepts
here how about a fabric in space-time
are we saying that space is a physical
object is that what we're saying here is
a physical object is is time a physical
object they're not these are euphemisms
these are figures of speech that have
been introduced like the word particle
which is not a particle is rooted not a
corpuscle you know we're dealing with
abstractions you know these people are
not physicists they're extra sis as I
call them because all they do is
abstract I need to know up physical
object that's why I'm saying the first
equations we need to have a physical
object at the end of the yellow brick
road all right so let's take it to the
next next step the next level of coming
up with and I can describe some but some
you know some describe their
descriptions of space-time at least we
call it space-time as a fabric now we
can and we will bring this up sure and
by the third you know the space-time is
a fabric obviously it's not well okay
it's depends on what you mean by space
and time we would need to define that
short but at least we can say that you
could have a fabric that has something
associated with space and it seems to me
it seems to change with time you know
this agree to that but that's why I
start at the beginning the beginning is
physics requires an object and we need
to define what an object is for the
purposes of physics in physics requires
an object space-time does not qualify as
an object first because it's
unimaginable it's four-dimensional and
they say they'll try to imagine this and
that is that you can't draw it you can't
make a picture of it so what are we
talking about - you can I read it from
from the Guru of physics so called
physics I'll read it to you if you don't
mind just two seconds and I think it
won't do that I'm not debating him I'm
not debating him
you look let me say here that says
listen listen to what he says a four
dimensional space called space-time it
is impossible to imagine a four
dimensional space Stephen Hawking in his
book a brief history of time it is
impossible a four-dimensional space no
because he's trying to imagine a concept
of course he can't picture it
so you're big enough you're bringing up
Stephen Hawking who had was a chair of
mathematical physics as your argument
you're really picking holding this this
this this statement you're making really
so you're picking out he's not the only
person who has said that there are lots
of physicists said you can't imagine
space in fact all you have to do is draw
it just draw them we'll know if you
can't draw it obviously there's no such
thing as space-time I watched a movie
recently and they had a four-dimensional
space illustrated as a tesseract
it was like cubes and it was a list of
infinite cubes and you could travel
between the cubes and you find yourself
a different point in time isn't the
satisfactory
isn't it a satisfactory illustration
bill you have a three-dimensional cube
representing a two-dimensional screen
that's what I see I don't see a
four-dimensional anything because no one
can even imagine a 4d anything there's
no such thing the universe entirely from
here on to the to to God to heaven all
there is a 3d there's no 2d there's no
1d there's no 3d and no 0b no 14 no 0d
there's only 3d anything outside the 3d
does not belong to physics
so to that I would disagree and the way
but that's what you have to say what is
an iPad let's nail it down so what is it
empty
so so in object your point was it has
something that has size by the way we've
got then we have to throw away particles
because some particles we don't know at
least what their size is or maybe you
would say that they do have sizes we
just need
and that's where you stand there
he has just listened to mr. Sean Carroll
I assume you heard of him Sean Carroll
says that there are no such things as
particles stop thinking of particles he
says all particles are fields vibration
of the fields so we have a field which
is a concept is that's just a bunch of
values and he's saying there's a
vibration of all these concepts so we
have no particles even you know what are
we talking about then what is it answers
no so build the view okay two things
first I want to make sure that it that
there's not a little bit of disconnect
and you get the papers that I sent you
okay thank you thank you go to this okay
so I am NOT Sean Carroll we're not
talking about Sean Carroll you can go to
Cal you can go to California and speak
to him I suppose
let me just but for just one second in
the four four or five here that papers
that you sent to me write that I looked
at they invoke particles so hopefully
you'll tell me what a particle is is in
your religion if it's not what mr.
Carroll says yes yes I wasn't the author
many of those papers those are his I
understand I understand but you know if
your other particles near linguistically
short can but of course my point was
only the fact that we don't know what
the particle size to us so say that it
has shape well that's a little bit
uncertain we have our doing experiments
for example at the moment to come up
with precision tests of what is the
shape of the electron we don't know yet
we don't know this if the electron size
because as far as down as we can try to
probe it which seems to have either it
seems to depending on how we we probe it
we have we run into some problems and
that
other particles are produced as a result
such an issue where where the theorist
has to make an assumption this is not a
question of using a microscope this is
not a question of running an experiment
this is an issue where the person has to
step back do some armchair physics he
stood back and tries to think and says
what could it be what could it look like
for example let me give you an example I
think we'll never know by the way
because I can come up with we'll never
know really what what it is because the
other armchair guy next door will also
be able to come up with an equally valid
idea yes in science we have no use for
knowledge so we never know is not
important in science in science we have
to explain for this you make an
assumption and say let us assume the
electron is a particle a little ball
fine then we make an assumption we say
ok now let me explain the mechanism of
for example quantum jump oh how how an
atom works then you can explain it but
if then you say you know I don't know
what an electron looks like well who
cares what it looks like at that point
at that point all we need to know is I'm
gonna make an assumption that it's a
ball ok so then I guess we can we can
say that we maybe don't so this is
interesting in light of your what your
hope rope hypothesis and that you know
asking questions about you know for how
does it behave in certain situations if
I don't know it's throughout the the
properties of this rope it becomes
challenging for me to actually even
identify doesn't even conform with
knowing physics such as the one that I
brought up previously where if you have
a light it's a it's a problem of
induction essentially it's sort of a
unification of the Maxwell's equations
that you have two antennas and you
rotate one versus the other you light up
one it lights up in one configuration
and it doesn't light up in another
configuration polarized you know
for example look at that picture you
drew there the one that you've got on
the board I assume that the star
that at the top is a star faraway star
right and it's uh that's the Sun so I
mean it's a it's a picture that we're
going to you can describe multiple it
was a little bit of a but we can we can
start with this as being the star and
you know either objects behind it you
know of course it could it doesn't it
can be directly behind it it can be
slightly behind but you would otherwise
perhaps or it could even be over here
for example and then you get some
bending you to the Stars presence or not
yes question is do we bend or do we what
is it
deflect is it the same thing to say Ben
to say deflect I mean is the little
photon or are we talking about a beam I
thought we already established that it's
most that systems are most likely
physical we don't need to we don't need
to get into semantics arguments I mean I
it goes to those two the best theory if
the if these are photons individual
photons then light has not bent the
photon has been diverted deflected
that's the correct my point is that you
are are requiring a precision of
language absolutely because otherwise I
don't understand your theory what are
you saying are you saying that it's a
stick and I bent it is that what you're
saying are you saying that a little
particle just went around the garbage of
space-time okay mechanisms
oh man the question becomes okay if you
have so I have my my eraser towel of
course and then the question is if you
put a massive object say my timer which
I haven't said yes and for example I
sent some sort of particle through it
would you say that Ben's I'm not really
sure what you're going to describe this
is this is quite literally how he
described though space no the object
bins I'll just do around it and then and
then as a result other particles which
can event space in the same way just
like a trampoline you can be
we'll move in a different way because of
the fabric of the space yeah this
simultaneous it bends now to your point
about can you imagine something
four-dimensional one could imagine okay
now how you just project that to three
dimensions and that's tricky it's more
than drink it's impossible I don't know
why it's impossible you can describe you
cannot imagine four dimensions to begin
with there is four dimensions - oh so -
take it - taking it one can use
analogies short now to take your analogy
that you use in the past with magnets
for example if your it fluid for example
and you've drop in a magnet say the
fluid is a colloidal food I think it's
called it has little tiny magnets that
are all inside of the the objects little
objects will start to bend toward the
the magnet in the flute so this would if
you think of the little colloidal
objects as part of the fabric then you
can then talk about other magnets which
start moving around inside this little
magnetic fluid so take an example I know
you might like that because it's it
pushes your all all electromagnetic
system
Pirie I would say perhaps by the way
that not all systems interact not all
particles that we know at the very least
interact by we don't know and that we
would say that we don't we're strong
suggesting to think that they don't
interact all indirect by charge that's
one of the biggest problems with the
theory but we'll put that to the side
for now the fact that some particles do
not interact because they may not have
charged neutrinos is the good example or
is the example that we know of that I
would say would be the most solid but I
think the analogy you just gave involved
only 3d objects
so it's an analogy something that we are
familiar with but space no one can al
achieve our space-time because there is
no four-dimensional object that we can
imagine so what is freaky it's tricky it
is tricky
yes but at the very least it describes
the process that's a
if for example when you lived in some
sort of fluid I'm not saying that we do
is show you sort of deep this would be
an ether Theory essentially we have some
sort of fluid that such that objects
move in that fluid in a way that it
bends I guess or I don't remember what
go deflects I it doesn't matter to me
but as a result of this this meat this
fluid because of other objects I'm fine
I'm fine with this interpretation it's
not perhaps not the only interpretation
but it's an interpretation that is could
be valid but you see you see you just
said it doesn't matter to you whether it
bends or deflects and it changes your
theater you changes your mechanism
whether you mad
whether you use a little ball I'm laid
out I laid out the model I'm only it's
it's real I get your your your need to
be precise precision in words but very
only contention in that is that you know
we use lots of words and then shorthand
in your mind you might come up with this
word or this word in this word and by
mistake it's hard to conform to this
object oriented world view so that's my
only it's really a limitation of my mind
to come up with the correct word at the
moment so I my only contention with that
is let's not get into that aspect of the
semantics because I understand your
point and I'm not let's let's put that
to this let's put the interpretation I'm
granting at most I'm granting the
interpretation of objective only that's
not the problem here but you see you see
that there's a difference right between
bending a rod like if I were to explain
to you something and I say yeah thinking
a rod is not the same thing as swerving
a ball throwing a curveball for example
you know these are two different
mechanisms so if we're gonna talk about
photons we have to it's not a question
of semantics it's a question that goes
to the root of the theory okay so you
know bending of light Jimmy is a very
tricky Jimmy
people keep saying bending of light and
people get the idea that oh somehow
worse face bent light when that's not
the case that's not what the guy is
saying the guy is really saying that the
bowling ball went around a curve that's
different so let's let's let's let's so
let's let's it agree to agree I suppose
on your contention and let's move on and
ask for an example if we take the fluid
example of these objects the question
for the Rope hypothesis is does is does
your sit does your model map to a
potential we call these this fabric of
potential in mathematics does this
object conform to potential
interpretation of quantum or I guess
particle mechanics well going again with
that picture you've got behind you
I can explain that in a different way
than using for diamonds unimaginable
four-dimensional space-time I listen
listen listen just for a second I can
see look at those lines that you've got
behind you those lines are the ropes
that interconnect the light coming out
of that star in the background all the
way to the the Sun to the corona of the
Sun and then relay that signal to the
earth okay we don't mean it's it's
straightforward perfect okay so now I'm
going to do reorganize this this picture
okay we can exchange this so we have a
brief we've agreed that this is a photon
and we agree of this is a star but let's
change the star to the Sun hey I was
thinking instead of a star but well I
don't know what you're yeah it's the
same okay it's the same and for this
purpose if you're gonna talk about
microscopic phenomena let's move it down
to two details that I mean we don't know
much about gravity so it's it's there
it's still quite speculative at least
and I know that you wanted to describe
those things but at least you won't have
too much disagreement with your rope I
thought
this is using star we always get down
double slipped okay so you have for
example your rope so you have your
minute group and your is it is this
accurate is it that there you have two
ropes and that's exactly what's going to
get unwind and they've come back
together or is it are they two separate
ropes in the SS and we're joined by two
separate ropes do separate ropes
alright so now let me change that a
little bit and I'm gonna put consider
them so typically when we do this
experiment okay one can choose how these
from the source how they combine okay
okay instead of instead of them coming
back and recombining let's then they to
or let's say let's lower the intensity
of our light source such that it comes
here or here and we organize our
experiments such that it lands both
either here or here
why does with does this occur meaning
I'll be more specific the you have
apertures for example I can move my
apertures just that only this light NATO
through these two these two directions
or I can change my experiment such that
it comes here the rope here the Rope
would be over here it would if I have
sent one light particle at a time why
does the light particle is eclipse on my
detector here sometimes and then here
other times this is called the beam
splitter by the way a beam splitter self
you understand my listen you think I do
that's here let's see if I get you're
saying the source is the one on the top
right that's okay you're saying there's
light going to the slits and then what's
that point they're right under the
little end point where right above there
is that one yeah at that point no right
above it you got a point where it
deflects yeah yeah
no the point that you don't even want go
straight and suddenly it deflects you
see ya there
the last one you raised nothing it's
just a light source okay places you're
saying that the light goes and somehow
deflects I'm saying that I'm going to
set up my apertures meaning people's
yeah that's that's a the pinhole goes
through here or goes through here to pay
fine and that's a working mode
essentially okay so you're saying that
the rope from the light source is
connected to the slit and the slit is
connected to that end to the screen or
the detector I know I didn't say that
well that's what I see so practically
classically okay if you shine light down
here okay you'll see light particles
you'll see like all the detector I'll
detect a signal here and almost no
signal here does that make sense yeah
and what's the with the Rope model you
have the light source connected to the
slid to the app and the nd aperture is
made out of atoms and it's relaying the
signal to the detector so there's an
interaction okay that's fine but we get
it
ah that may be the case don't an extra
play by though you've already you've
already pinned yourself to an extra
interpretation that the mathematic
mathematicians don't necessarily claim a
curse but and that's what but your claim
is that somehow there is some
interaction I don't know this is empty
space but you're saying about interact
with this list well keep in mind that we
don't need the slits to do the slit
experiment that's the first error well
it's it's it's useful for us like sort
of forcing the light to go in the
direction that we want it to go well why
can't you put a needle we do it with a
needle and it works fine but my point is
if you use double slits then I can force
the like particle difficult you're here
or there yeah but what you're doing by
putting the slit keep in mind putting
options yeah by putting the slit you you
have the idea or the mathematicians have
the idea that what's happening here is
that light is a photon so that's already
an error that's let's ignore the
interpretation for a moment yeah but
what I'm saying is see what you've got
there is that you have a rope connected
to the slit and another atom from the
slit is connected to through with a rope
to the connector that's what you have so
I'm not sure what this changes in any
way you see what I'm saying I'm saying
that the thing you're having a light
source right the light source is made
out of atoms that's the source of light
and I'm saying that that atom there the
one that's being stimulated is already
connected to an atom in the slit and the
and another atom are the same atom in
the slit or several of those atoms are
connected to the with ropes to the
detector so so what you tell those that
line that arrow that you drew are we're
going to replace them with ropes and we
have two sets of yet so okay so if I
lower the intensity
the light I don't get a click on my
detector either here or here if I go
over the intensity so one particle at a
time or one whatever a grope at a time
sorry and I use the word row one row at
a time it will the rope will see a
detector bringing this work or what this
one what it would me to it the first
step explain why the ropes hit one or
the other by the way I should mention
that this is not this is a phenomena
that occurs not just with ropes I can do
it with electrons as well yeah so been
questioned he seems to be saying that
there is a quantum nature to the
reaction we see there a digital yes or
no the photon passes or doesn't pass us
and it can only pass in one of the slits
at a time how does the rope hypothesis
approach this question of quantum
quantum behaviour our flight well that's
why I'm saying what we have here is a
problem and the problem is that we see
light is a series of particles and you
cannot explain the slit experiment with
particles very simply because we replace
the slit with a needle that's what I'm
saying he's made it's more complicated
we put a needle instead of two slits and
there's no way the particles are going
to turn the corner and go inwards at
least you got it you haven't you would
have to explain by what physical
mechanism the particles bend the corner
around the needle because I've done it
with a needle and you produce the
fringes anyways so there's no bending
here by the way they're going it's going
in a straight line
I designed it such that they're going in
straight line no no you don't need to
worry about bending of of the rope yeah
but you're not producing the slit
experiment what it would this is not a
slit this is a slit experiment there's
one slip and another slopes now the
question becomes what determines whether
there I can detect the Rope on this one
or this why does it sometimes why is it
sometimes that atoms on this side
interact and
other in other instances the were often
addressed with this group of addicts in
our neighboring the slips yours claiming
that somehow it seems what you're
claiming is that there's interactions
occurring there one would think for
example if I if I make it then I make
the distances very triangular one would
assume that the interaction between this
drove these particles and the source and
these particles and of course it would
be about equal why does it sometimes
interact with these ones more than these
ones in your rope hypothesis well I'd
have to look at the experiment see you
know how much motion there is I mean
we'd have to measure and find out if the
you know the distances are the same I
mean I don't know I have to look at this
in more detail but I'm not sure what
this explains because how can you
explain this with particles for example
same same set up what's the explanation
with particles because the particle
should go also unless you could be at
two places at once which is what quantum
says which is nonsense but I would say
that we can do this with electrons or
electrons ropes or electrons if the
electrons are particles but if electrons
are not particles and it's nonsense also
because the first thing whom you would
have to explain with electric the first
thing you would have to explain with
electrons is what the atom looks like if
the electron is a bead that goes around
the atom what keeps it tied to the atom
that's the first thing we have to do we
have to start at the beginning not at
the end we have to start with the basics
what does an atom look like okay let's
let's start with an atom of course you
have protons and neutrons on your
nucleus and your electron okay simple
enough we can do the experiment with
atoms at this point we've got we've
advanced in the in the science such that
we can do the same experiment with atoms
yeah the question becomes can we can see
the atoms which to emphasize the nucleus
has a finite size so I can start talking
about shapes of we're going to call that
I think it would make
since they call that a particle I mean
if you have an interpretation that says
otherwise it's it's really made of gross
then I mean my goodness is about too
much of the difference I have I have yet
to see a quantum atom what does an atom
look like can you draw it there I'm sure
you can because no one has ever done it
I mean what does an atom look a quantum
atom look like what does it look like is
it a little bead that's going around
nucleus so the problem is that we can
probe an electron we know it is moving
it is moving with respect to the mean if
it's moving with respect to it we do
know that you're interpreting before you
can say that you have to draw the atom
before you can say that okay okay before
we get there I just wanted to show my
own my own image that I found from
Google I don't know if it will convince
Bill but I just wanted to troll a little
bit with it here's the structure of atom
Bill what's happening I got your atom
it's the strontium atom it's a spot
right there let's figure so that we can
really see it okay let me try to zoom it
here's your atom by the way I should say
you don't want to look at it because you
just want to sit in an armchair and just
hypothesize about you don't want to be
experimental your head I want to say
what you're thinking about because their
goal is for you to draw out anything
you're gonna try to pin me down and
that's fine so you have for example we
have an idea that there are presumably
things inside of the nucleus you know we
don't quite understand what's inside the
nucleus a whole lot we know we have
for us again we might have other people
call the electron put the electron
somewhere okay you're taking your
neighbor you're gonna get nucleus the
nucleus is easy let's let's look at the
electron so let's assume for example
we'll start with the interpretation the
realists interpretation because I know
you like the realest interpretation
let's just you're gonna pin it down
that's fine you don't know this for sure
couple things down if there is an
electron that exists that in a single
point in space I can detect so far as I
know I can detect the particle in
location so we can say with the pretty
high degree of accuracy that there is
something associated with it these
particle like this is the electron and
this is my Neutron so we I think you'll
understand these parts what keeps the
electron tied to the nucleus why does it
fly away what physical entities the
electric died to the nucleus but we are
our the mathematics points to photons
and those photons are considered virtual
because hold on I would say we're close
ritual that's just it this might be a
misnomer in your in your but let's not
let some the finish exact not virtuous
man do you want to look at ok if you
want to look it up on Google you'd have
to look up virtual ok if you want to
take this is this is if we want to take
an interpretation you can talk about an
electromagnetic potential like a
potential most like this potential of
space-time here we can talk about
potential associated with the weak
environment of fabric which bends the
electron moving towards and away from
the electron what physical entity our no
potential is not a physical entity the
potential the fabric fabric what is a
fabric what fabric are we talking about
what that does we know space
electromagnetic electromagnetic a fabric
that's not a food that's not a physical
entity that's why I'm saying you have to
draw of an object is that which has
shape you have to draw
you're getting your became too pedantic
here what is that what is how is a
fabric more or less of an entity than a
rope a fat will draw it what fabric so
me that you have to draw it to draw a
fabric well I'm not the I'm not a great
artist but what is that what have you
drawn are you doing space you're saying
space is a fabric I mean you can draw a
rag bill a rag is dry and it's a
clattering draw like that one there I
can okay what if I take everything that
Peter said for the last minute and I
change the word fabric for rug what is
the electron bend space-time built
fabric
what is it what is this bent fabric what
is this rope I can go to the hardware
store and get you a rope but when you
say what is it broke Nina we can ask
that question
fabric made of you can say that yes you
can ask the same question but we can't
answer this unless you just a allude the
question there's no Gina this fabric
I've never heard of this fabric in
quantum mechanic a so we can talk about
the fabric cuz I said you paper about
yeah but then if you're gonna talk about
the fabric you better and be able to
draw the fabric before you can just talk
about it
I can draw a rope you can't wrong I
don't know what that is that I see a
bunch of line I'm not if you'd like me
the tape the rope the piece of fabric on
the wall we could do that if you like
okay you're saying that you saying that
the fabric looks like that rag this the
fabric you have a
I would say a better interpretation is a
fluid because it's three-dimensional
that's a fluid this is what I'm not
saying that this is the case but it's a
fluid where you have particles inside
this fluid that would be an ether theory
I think that you're improvising with
this is not everybody I sent you the
paper of a potential the first paper
residential it's not a physical object
but they call it potential but it's a
fact but we call the potential for all
six purposes the potential is the
mathematical object which describes in
your interpretation in your physical
your physicalist interpretation let's
get the mathematical pulling society
that doesn't matter in this debate your
your your a light know your keep on
bringing it up you you don't need to
bring up meat we're on the same page but
and you're so exchanged the words
potential and fabric only for the
purpose of that's the word that I'm more
used to say that's all okay let's let's
stay with the fabric what happens when
the electron leaves as a fabric stay
there how far does this fabric extend
all the way to the other atom I mean
what is this fabric I never heard of
this this this fabric this fabric is if
you're heard of a voltage yeah I heard
also is that what you're referring to
another word for field no a field is not
the same as a voltage no no field is the
same thing as a fabric is that what
you're calling it a fabric a field a
voltage would be one description what's
going on associated with this fabric
it's essentially a property of the
fabric now to clarify for our audience
Peter are you what you're proposing here
is this the same thing as quantum field
theory where the quantum properties of
field are are given to a space that
that's what we're talking about or am i
confused so if we I perhaps you have
given another link to a video by I think
it's PBS space time talks about quantum
realism so they describe this fabric it
would be called it's a potential they
describe it in terms of its
there's something called the bow Miam
interpretation of quantum mechanics that
you can use to describe this the
potential or the fabric of space so that
was one interpretation so he took a very
literal interpretation similar to fill
here and but instead of using ropes he
just could be describing in terms of
potentials talking about if you have
instead of just fabric if you sit in
front of this image here if you have the
capacitor
I shouldn't have erased it but we'll get
back to it if you have a capacitor you
can describe it in terms of the field in
terms of ropes your your are bill ropes
these electric ropes or you can describe
it so here you have a charm here you
have Q and another minus Q for example
you can describe it in terms of like a
rope in terms of ropes you can just as
easily describe it in terms of a fabric
where in in the two-dimensional
representation it's like a slide large
particles like to thank towards one
fabric rather than the other and the
particles slide from one to the other so
bill have we reached with this recent
clarification a a duel a duel rope rag
theory of your ropes I mean what could
you conceive of your ropes being a
fabric could we sue a close with your
maybe not it sounds like the emperor's
rag maybe maybe maybe those is the
emperor here who doesn't have clothes
but in any case
[Laughter]